[Applause]
frustrated
and angry thousands of farmers occupy
india's most prominent landmark
the iconic red fort walking highways and
roads
they say new agricultural laws being
introduced by the government
will devastate their livelihoods and
favor large companies
what began as protests two months ago
has turned into a movement
with farmers marching into the center of
india's capital
in the outskirts of new delhi police
fire tear gas
when a group of farmers breached
security barricades with their tractors
the demonstrations coincide with india's
republic day
as farmers rallied nearby this
is what another side of the capital
looked like on tuesday morning
a festive display of the country's
cultural diversity
and military strength
the entire country watches delhi on
republic day so when the farmers roll
their tractors into delhi
then the message goes out that the
farmer's fight is not yet over
it's just started we are fighting for
our rights by entering the city
opposition to three agricultural laws
passed in november is challenging the
authority of prime minister narendra
modi
the reforms will relax rules on the sale
price and storage
of farm produce the government says the
changes will boost incomes and private
investments
but farmers say they're an invitation
for conglomerates to take over
agriculture in india
we're calling for the modi government to
take back these three laws
so that the farmers get their rights
back the government has passed these
laws without any discussions without any
thought
they just imposed them
about half of the country's 1.3 billion
people work in agriculture
the government's offered to delay the
new laws for 18 months
have been rejected by farmers
they say they will continue protesting
until the laws
are fully repealed
al jazeera masami singh is the deputy
editor of india today
and is at the protests so clearly
we have learned that the delhi police
has clamped down
on the internet as far as the national
capital pockets are concerned
and right now it is a very uh
very testing situation for the modi
government because
right now after a parade uh really
reached the red spot
another parade has taken off and it's
enroute to the red fort
and that is the symbolic uh symbolic
gesture that the farmers are doing a
wavering off from the route that was
designated by the delhi police
so in the national capital we've seen
multiple parades
and uh the government has been on a very
nervous wicket
on this one because the farmer's issue
has always been a very sensitive one
and the narendra modi government had
come riding on the plank
of uh the welfare of farmers so it is a
very sensitive issue
that's one reason that we see that the
delhi police had even granted permission
uh to the farmers to do the parade on
selective routes
but right now what we witness in the
national capital
is that several tractors are marching
towards the red fort
in a move to show their anger and their
resentment
towards the modi government has acted on
this issue
it created a law and order problem in
the national capital